>>female presenter: Welcome to Authors at
Google.
I'm Rebecca Moore, and I'm privileged to introduce
our speaker Dr. Victoria Sweet.
I was going to talk about her new book, God's
Hotel: a Doctor, a Hospital, and a Pilgrimage
to the Heart of Medicine.
The book launched just one month ago.
I think, as Googlers, we can relate to working
long and hard on something, maybe for more
than a year.
You're passionate about it, you launch it,
and then you wait with some trepidation to
see what's going to happen.
Well, the great news is that God's Hotel is
taking off like a rocket ship.
We're very privileged to have Dr. Sweet with
us here to talk about it.
In its first week, it made it onto the San
Francisco Chronicle Best Sellers list.
Two days ago, it was just reviewed by the
New York Times' Science Times, who called
it "transcendent and a tour de force."
Congratulations on that.
Dr. Sweet is both a physician and a prize-winning
historian with a Ph.
D. in history and social medicine.
She's also associate clinical professor of
medicine at UC San Francisco, and I'm personally
happy to say that she studied mathematics
and Greek at Stanford University.
Go Stanford.
[laughter]
There will be time for Q&A at the end, and
Victoria will sign books for those of you
who would like them.
Finally, just on a personal note, I've known
Victoria for many, many years.
She has always been someone who was comfortable
taking the road less traveled.
I think, now, with God's Hotel, she's created
a whole new road to a place and time that
few of us even knew existed.
And now she's here to tell us about it.
Please welcome Dr. Victoria Sweet.
[applause]
>>Victoria Sweet: Is that microphone working?
Well, thank you very much, Rebecca.
Thank you all for being here today.
Thanks Google for letting me speak here.
Laguna Honda Hospital was like no hospital
I had ever seen or even imagined.
I got there kinda accidentally.
I had decided to go back to school to get
my Ph.
D. in medical history after I had been practicing
medicine for many years.
Laguna Honda was the only place that would
let me practice medicine part time.
So I went over for my interview.
When I saw it for the first time, I was nonplussed.
It was high on a hill, overlooking the ocean,
and it looked like a medieval, Romanesque
monastery.
It had peach colored walls, a red tiled roof,
a bell tower, and turrets.
After my interview, the medical director took
me out to show me around.
She showed me the long, open wards that go
all the way back to when monks took care of
the sick poor in the monasteries for free.
When went upstairs and she showed me the surgery
suite, which looks like where Humphrey Bogart
had his face redone in "Man Without a Face."
We walked past the old-fashioned beauty salon
with its steel helmet hairdryers.
She showed me the library, the auditorium,
and the chapel, which was really more like
a small church with polished wooden pews,
stained glass windows, and the stations of
the cross along the walls.
Then we went out and she showed me the gardens.
Turned out that Laguna Honda had been the
almshouse for the city, and it was on 62 acres.
It is still on 62 acres of land in the middle
of San Francisco.
The gardens are extensive.
She showed me the greenhouse, the aviary,
and the little barnyard.
So the patients could pot plants, watch chickens
hatch from eggs, and even see animals, even
if they were bed-bound.
Then we walked back to her office, and she
offered me the job.
I didn't know.
I wasn't sure.
I told her I would come for two months, but
I stayed for 20 years.
Turned out to be a wonderful place to practice
medicine.
Part of that was the place itself.
The place was a great place to practice medicine
in terms of its spaciousness, kinda ramshackle.
But what really made it incredible were the
patients, because it turns out that Laguna
Honda was the original almshouse for the city.
That was how we used to take care of the sick
poor.
That's how we used to take care of the sick
poor before there was health insurance.
There would be a free county hospital and
a free county almshouse.
The acutely ill would be taken care of in
the free county almshouse-- county hospital.
And then, if they needed additional care or
nobody new what else to do with them, they
were transferred to the almshouse.
It used to be that every county in the country
had a free county hospital and a free county
almshouse, and that was how we took care of
the sick poor.
Starting in the '50s, the almshouses across
the United States were closed, and many of
the county hospitals, except for San Francisco,
which still has its county hospital and still
has its almshouse, albeit now called a hospital.
So the patients, as you can imagine, are the
bottom 0.1% of the population.
What I've found is that they were two standard
deviations from the mean.
Any mean.
They were the tallest and the shortest, the
fattest and the thinnest, the nicest and the
meanest, of any patients I ever had.
They had every disease, too.
They taught me a tremendous amount about medicine
and health care, cure and caring, efficiency
and inefficiency.
The two months went by, and then a year or
two, and I really didn't notice that the years
had gone by or that I was learning a lot from
the patients until I got to my patient, Mrs.
Todd. [pause] Ms. Todd was 35 years old.
She had cancer.
Her cancer was brain cancer.
What made it horrible was that it was just
behind her right eye, and it had grown, in
spite of surgery and radiation, right out
of her eye.
The surgeons had removed the eye and sewn
the eyelid down over the cancer, but the cancer
was still growing.
Ms. Todd had never been beautiful, but what
with the radiation, which had caused her hair
to fall out, the steroids, which had caused
her face to balloon, and the sewn eyelid,
she was very hard to look at.
Yet she was pleasant and quiet.
She always smiled as I passed her by.
Eventually, we were on speaking terms, with
a quick "Hello" and "How are you?"
from me to her and from her to me.
I got used to her deformity, although only
by blocking out, in some way, my experience
of her experience.
One day, I finally braved my reluctance and
stopped by her bed, full stop.
We looked at each other.
She at me: white coated and rushed, a bit
disheveled.
I looked only at her left eye.
"Is there anything I can do for you?"
I asked her after we talked a bit.
"Yes," she replied, "there is.
I really don't like the food they're giving
me.
It's all cut up and bland.
Do you think it could be changed?
And another thing.
Could you arrange for me to visit the eye
doctor?
I need a new pair of glasses."
I was, and am to this day, floored by her
response.
I was, and am, awestruck by such equanimity.
She wanted, not euthanasia or a miraculous
cure, stronger pain medication, or a second
opinion, but different food, a pair of glasses.
She said nothing about her terrible misfortune.
She was calm, matter-of-fact.
Somehow, she'd accepted her fate.
It was the small things, the little daily
things, that were important to her.
We did change her diet, and we did get her
new glasses.
Not long after, she moved to another ward,
and there she died peacefully, 18 months later.
Ms. Todd capped my experience of those first
years of Laguna Honda.
She summarized it and hinted at what I would
be learning later.
Even when there's nothing to do for a patient,
no cancer to discover, no paradoxical pulse
to take, there is still something to do.
It doesn't have to be life saving, grandiose,
and heroic.
It can be as simple as a pair of glasses or
a different diet.
In fact, it usually is.
[pause] [clattering]
I learned a tremendous amount from the patients
at Laguna Honda.
If I had to summarize what I learned in one
sentence, it would be that the practice of
medicine is a personal relationship between
doctor and patient.
And when it's personal, it works.
The best way, the easiest way I can explain
what I mean is to tell you the story of Dr.
Curtis and the case of the missing shoes.
[pause] I learned a lot from Dr. Curtis, but
it was in the case of the missing shoes that
he taught me the most about care and caring,
time and inefficiency.
On this particular day, I met him by accident
in the wide-windowed corridor that ran the
length of the hospital and connected all the
wards.
He was in a hurry.
"Where was he going?"
I asked.
"Back to the rehabilitation ward," he said,
where he was covering for a few weeks.
The rehabilitation ward was its own mini hospital
within Laguna Honda.
It admitted the patients with the milder strokes
and the less traumatic head injuries, most
of whom would recover and be discharged back
to their homes, if they had them.
Although its patients, too, were often without
friends, money, or health insurance, like
the admitting ward, it had its own physicians
to admit, examine, and discharge its patients.
This month, Dr. Curtis was one of them.
He'd just returned from outside the hospital,
he told me, and was heading back to a patient
who, having been rehabilitated after a stroke,
had been ready for discharge for months.
Every day, when Dr. Curtis made his rounds,
checking on the 36 patients on the ward, this
patient was still there, still zipping around
in his wheelchair, still going to therapy.
Finally, Dr. Curtis said, "I asked him why,
since he was able to walk, he was still here.
Why was he still in the wheelchair?
Why hadn't he been discharged?"
"No shoes, doc.
They ordered me special shoes, but they're
waiting for Medicaid to approve them."
"How long have they been waiting?"
Dr. Curtis asked.
"Three months."
Dr. Curtis thought a bit.
"What size shoe do you wear?"
"Size 9."
Dr. Curtis reflected for a while.
He thought about his duties, his other patients,
the charts he had to dictate, the quality
assurance forms he had to fill out.
Then he left the hospital, got in his car,
and drove to Wal-Mart, where he bought a pair
of size 9 running shoes for $16.99.
He'd just come back with the shoes and was
going over to the ward to put them on the
patient and write the discharge orders.
"Was he planning to submit his receipt for
reimbursement?"
I asked.
He laughed.
As I watched him hurry back to the rehabilitation
ward, I wondered.
Why had Dr. Curtis done this, and why hadn't
anyone else?
It was a simple thing to do, but it never
would have occurred to me to do it.
I would've been frustrated with the shoe delay,
of course, and I would have filled out a second
or even a third Medicaid form.
I might even have written Medicaid, or braved
its phone tree to complain about the time
that pair of shoes was taking.
But it would never have occurred to me to
go to Wal-Mart and buy the patient's shoes.
I had too much to do, too many forms to fill
out, too many other patients to see.
It would have meant crossing an inefficiency
boundary.
And yet, Dr. Curtis got in his car without
much questioning and was hurrying back to
the ward with the shoes to put them on the
patient himself.
He reminded me of an aphorism I loved but
had never understood.
"The secret in the care of the patient is
in caring for the patient."
I'd always assumed that mean caring about
the patient, loving or at least liking the
patient, but when I saw Dr. Curtis rushing
off to put shoes on a patient he barely knew,
I thought there must be more to it than that.
So I tracked down the quote and found it in
a talk by Dr. Francis Peabody to the graduating
medical class of Harvard in 1927.
Turned out that Dr. Peabody didn't mean caring
about a patient, but caring for a patient,
which he explained meant doing the little
things, the little personal things that nurses
usually do: adjusting a patient's bedclothes,
giving him sips of water.
That took time, Dr. Peabody admitted, and
wasn't perhaps the most efficient way for
doctors to spend their time, but it was worth
it, he told his students, because that kind
of time costly caring was what created the
personal relationship between patient and
doctor.
And that relationship was the secret of healing.
[pause]
In the meantime-- [pause] In the meantime,
I'd started my Ph.
D. in medical history.
I was studying the medical writings of Hildegard
of Bingen.
Hildegard was a 12th century German nun.
She was also a visionary, a mystic, a composer,
and, as it turned out, a medical practitioner.
She'd written a book about medicine.
It was fascinating.
There was not the "eye of newt, toe of frog"
medicine I expected from a medieval medical
text.
It was real medicine from real patients with
real diseases that I could recognize.
But it was based on a completely different
idea of the body than our mechanical model.
Hildegard's idea was that the body was more
like a plant than a machine.
And the doctor more like a gardener than a
mechanic.
What's the difference?
The difference is that someone has to fix
a broken machine.
[pause] But a plant can heal itself.
[pause]
Hildegard called the power of a plant to heal
itself its viriditas, its greening power,
from the Latin "viridis", meaning "green."
She thought that human beings also had viriditas,
a natural power of healing, and that the doctor,
therefore, should be more like a gardener
cultivating that viriditas, removing obstructions
to it, nourishing it, than like a mechanic.
I didn't really understand what Hildegard
meant by viriditas until my patient Terry
Becker.
Terry Becker was one of my bad girls.
Actually, the New York Times called her the
"worst girl" and I thought that was actually
a good way to put it.
She was homeless and lived on the street with
her boyfriend, Mike.
She smoked and drank and used drugs.
One day, she woke up paralyzed from the neck
down.
She went to the county hospital, and they
discovered that she had a rare viral disease
called transverse myelitis, that has no treatment
but does tend to get better over time.
They sent her over to Laguna Honda.
She was on rehabilitation, and she did pretty
well.
She started to get better for about the first
two weeks.
But then the first of the month rolled around,
when the homeless in San Francisco get paid,
get welfare cash.
Mike, her cute boyfriend, showed up, and out
they went.
She disappeared for about a year.
Later, I found out that during that year,
she'd been seen in the emergency room at County
28 times, and had 3 long admissions to the
County.
Each time, just as she was getting better,
going out on the streets.
During that time, she developed a bedsore.
Mike also robbed her and beat her up.
She went back and forth to the County getting
very expensive operations to cover the bedsore
with a skin graft every time she went out.
Finally, the bedsore was too big to graft.
County didn't know what to do, and they sent
her over to Laguna Honda for treatment.
[pause] [clattering]
When I examined her, I was really quite shocked.
She didn't look-- She looked pretty sick.
She was only 37.
She looked like she was in her 50s at least.
It was the bedsore that really shocked me.
It was the worst I'd ever seen.
It was huge, enormous, and deep.
It went from the middle of her back all the
way down to her tail bone, and it spanned
both of her sitz bones.
The skin was completely gone, of course, but
so were the fat and the muscles that covered
the spine.
In their place was an unidentifiable mass
of decayed and decaying and infected tissue
from the failed skin grafts.
At the bottom of this wide, deep hole, I could
see bone: Terry's spine.
Terry's bedsore was scary.
She had no protection.
Everything delicate and crucial in her body--
bones, kidneys, spinal cord-- was exposed
and vulnerable to an environment full of germs.
Giving antibiotics to try to prevent infection
wouldn't work because the bacteria would get
resistant to them.
The bedsore really was too big to graft, even
if the surgeons agreed.
It would have to heal on its own, and that
would take years.
In the meantime, what chance did Terry have
of not getting an overwhelming infection that
would kill her?
I walked back to our little doctors' office
and sat down at my rickety desk.
I stared for quite a while at the wooden shelf
on which was Mrs. McCoy's robust plant, now
grown all over the wall.
The bedsore was a catastrophe, and possibly
the end of Miss Terry Becker.
The second time with the patient, I thought
about Hildegard.
I asked myself, "What would Hildegard do?
How would she treat Terry Becker's huge and
open wound?"
What she would do, I suddenly saw, was remove
obstructions to Terry's viriditas, because
if nothing was in its way, then viriditas
would heal her wound as surely as a plant
will grow green.
"What was in its way?"
I asked myself.
The massive dead tissue was in its way and
needed to be removed.
Any pressure on Terry's body from wrinkled
bedclothes, to hard mattresses, was in its
way and had to be removed.
Dirt, unkemptness, stale clothes, unnecessary
medications, fear, depression, all were in
its way.
My first job, therefore, as gardener doctor
was not to make a brilliant diagnosis or give
any magical medication, but remove obstructions
to Terry's own viriditas.
It was quite amazing how fast Hildegard's
prescription worked.
Within a few weeks, I began to see signs of
healing deep within Terry's wound.
There was no infection.
Deep down, at the base of the wound, is it
my imagination?
There was a smooth and pink glistening which
was starting to cover and protect the spine.
But then the first of the month rolled around,
and Mike showed up.
He was still pretty cute, still wearing his
tight Levi's, still walking with a flirtatious
though constrained strut.
The nurses made him wait in the smoking room.
Terry wheeled herself on her gurney, face
down, back covered, the whole length of the
ward.
Then she rolled into the smoking room.
They were in there a long time.
Then the door opened, and Mike came out and
left.
Terry had thrown him out.
She told him never to come back.
Then she stopped smoking, so her appetite
improved and she gained weight.
Without nicotine constricting her blood vessels,
the tiny new arteries and veins at the base
of her bedsore could absorb the vitamins and
protein she was eating, and the hole in her
backside began to fill in.
Since I did not check the bedsore daily, but
only once a week, its progress seemed as magical
to me as one of those time lapse movies they
showed us in school, where a plant grows from
a seed in a matter of minutes.
Terry's wound began to look like a huge scab.
The scab thickened until it was even with
the rest of the skin, and then just as petals
push against the constriction of the bud and
open it, the scab flaked off and there was
pink skin underneath.
That awful crater filled in from bottom to
top and from side to side.
It took a long time.
It took two and a half years.
But we were in no hurry, and neither was she.
[pause]
Terry changed the way I practiced medicine.
After that, I not only looked at patients
with the eye of the modern doctor, focusing
in on what was wrong with the patient and
how I could fix it, I also stepped back and
looked at the patient in the context of his
environment and asked myself, "Is there something
I can do to encourage this patient's viriditas?
Is there something I can do to remove what's
in the way?"
What I found was that this kind of slow medicine
worked very well for patients with slow diseases,
diseases that were long in developing, chronic
diseases, for which medicine had no really
good treatment.
I began to think of it as slow medicine as
opposed to the fast medicine that I also use,
which works so well for fast diseases: heart
attacks, appendicitis, cancer, but doesn't
work so well after the heart attack, the appendectomy,
the chemotherapy.
[pause]
Then, about halfway through my time at Laguna
Honda, things started to change.
There was a big push to turn the old fashioned
hospital into a modern health care facility.
There was a lot of battles, politics, and
struggles, especially between the director
of public health, whom I call Dr. Stein in
the book, and the doctors, nurses, and administrators
of Laguna Honda.
Finally, one day, Dr. Stein had had enough.
He replaced the medical director, the nursing
director, and the executive administrator
all at once with his own picks.
They were to come over to the hospital and
transform the hospital into a modern facility.
The name of the new executive administrator,
I call Mr. Conley.
This is what happened.
[pause] Mr. Conley was a bluff, hearty fellow
with an energetic, gravely voice, red hair,
and red beard.
He reminded me of the youngish Henry VIII
around the time he fell in love with Anne
Boleyn.
He was, as they said in the Middle Ages, Dr.
Stein's man.
His orders were to change Laguna Honda from
an old fashioned almshouse to a modern health
care and rehabilitation facility.
He had been warned by Dr. Stein about the
obstructions he would face: the balky doctors,
the obstreperous nun, the ex-director of nursing.
Mr. Conley was prepared.
But Mr. Conley, with the best will in the
world, eventually made a fatal mistake.
He stepped out of the administration wing
and met the patients of Laguna Honda.
I don't know how it happened, but I suppose
it had to do with the crashing of our computers.
Every computer in the hospital and everything
about them: email, printing, all the laboratory
data, all the forms.
The computers went down and stayed down for
months.
It was fortunate that the hospital was as
big and sloppy as it was, because not everything
was on those computers.
Most of us still had our books.
The telephones were still plugged into the
walls.
We still had our wooden mailboxes, overhead
paging, and clocks.
There was no email, however.
So instead of sitting in his re-redecorated
administration wing and shooting out electronic
missives, Mr. Conley had to scribble his messages
of pieces of paper, and when they were important,
deliver them himself.
Huffing and puffing, the whole long length
of the hospital, himself praying that the
elevator would start and not stop midway,
himself praying.
Passing the tattooed smokers in Harmony Park,
like the rest of us, Mr. Conley fell under
Laguna Honda's spell.
He began to say "Hello" to the patients he
passed.
He began to know some of them.
He began to visit them in their rooms and
on the open wards.
And he softened.
He got a bit confused.
Perhaps there were patients at Laguna Honda,
and not simply resident.
Perhaps Laguna Honda was a hospital, and not
a health care and rehabilitation facility.
So even after the computers were fixed, which
took four months, and I was surprised at how
much less work I had while they were down,
even including telephoning the lab for my
results, Mr. Conley continued to step out
of the administration wing and visit the patients.
Not with Miss Lester's compressed mouth and
eagle eye, but still he sat on beds, he talked,
he listened, and he learned about the hospital
from the patients' point of view, which would
be fatal.
Mr. Conley changed after that.
Not so much his decisions, which came down
from above, [pause] [knocking sound] but the
way he felt about his decisions, because he
knew the patients now.
He knew how his decisions would affect them.
What I learned from that is that it wasn't
only medicine that had to be personal.
Administration has to be personal, too.
[pause]
Over the past 20 years, I've watched medicine--
the pendulum of health care swing from the
personal to the efficient, and I have been
amazed by how inefficient that efficient health
care has turned out to be.
Healthcare costs keep rising astronomically
every year.
Patients, doctors, and even economists are
more and more frustrated.
Nobody seems to know what to do.
So let me end with showing you what happened
when modern, efficient health care landed
at Laguna Honda.
[pause]
What I did is I put together a graph over
the 20 years I was at Laguna Honda.
As cost-cutting measures, the patients were
gradually whittled down by about 40%, from
1178 to 780.
The doctors were also whittled down, from
about 32 to 9, about by 80%.
The clinical staff was whittled down by about
30%.
But the budget kept rising.
What's more, the total staff stayed the same.
Why was that?
We kept having more and more administration
and management.
[pause] In fact, by the time I left, the day
I left I looked around and realized that there
were more quality assurance managers at Laguna
Honda than there were doctors.
That was pretty scary.
What does all this new management do?
It's hard to know for sure, but the one thing
there are more of at Laguna Honda today than
when I started there is forms.
When I first got to Laguna Honda, there were
two forms of one page each.
The day before I left, I took out a random
chart, opened it up, and counted.
There were 43 forms, and most of them were
three, five, ten pages long.
I made a rather complicated scribbled graph
of this, but I think it's worthwhile looking
at it.
I don't have little pointers, so you just
have to follow me, but you can see the patients
in the blue in the middle are going down,
down, down, down.
The doctors, the physicians, in the black,
going down, down, down.
The budget, that blue line that just goes
up.
And the forms, which is the red line, going
way up.
I've actually pulled this out to, assuming
that the present trends continue, in 2024,
if they continue, there will be no patients
at Laguna Honda, [laughter], two physicians,
1400 FTE and a budget of 280 million dollars.
I think it's time for us to all work together
to give that pendulum of health care a nudge
backwards, towards the inefficient, the human,
and the personal.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
>>male#1: I had a question about the bad girl
patient.
>>Sweet: Yes.
>>male#1: What exactly was it that helped
her to turn around her life and break free
of her abusive, exploitive boyfriend?
>>Sweet: Yeah, yeah.
>>male#1: Is it about the care she received,
or was it something that she just had reached
a point where she knew it was either death
or completely transform her life?
Any idea?
>>Sweet: It's a great question.
Can everybody hear that?
Good.
Okay, great.
I think that's a beautiful question, actually,
to ask.
I ask myself that a lot.
I think there are two things.
That last time, Terry was way at the end of
the ward, and she had a very special nursing
assistant named Connie.
I noticed that Connie's patients always got
better.
It was just something about Connie.
She was also kinda trapped because she was
on that gurney lying down, face down, for
weeks.
I just think she had some kind of change of
heart.
It was really a very mysterious change of
heart, but that was her true healing.
In fact, the name of this chapter I called
the Miraculous Healing of Terry Becker.
And that, what you put your finger on, is
exactly the miracle, that she made that decision.
I don't really know why, but I do know that
decision stayed made, and that once she was
healed, and not only was she healed of her
bedsore, but by the time the bedsore was healed,
everything else about her was healed.
We'd found her family, which hadn't seen her
in 10 or 12 years.
Her family wanted to have her back home with
them.
We had a patient gift fund at Laguna Honda,
so we could get the money together to send
her back home.
She'd fattened up.
She had a whole personality change, from irritable,
frustrated, and kinda mean, to kind and grateful.
She was like a completely different person.
I know that she went back to her home and
stayed.
She never went back on the streets.
>>female #1: Going off from this last slide,
what do we do to make that happen?
>>Sweet: You know, I don't know quite the
answer to that, except I am getting so much
attention for this book and these ideas.
I feel a little bit like the kid in The Emperor's
New Clothes.
I'm like, "But there are just no clothes here.
I mean, come on, people.
Like, medicine is personal?
Is that the most unbelievably smart thing
you've ever heard?
No!
It's like, hello!
So I'm getting this kind of reaction from
people.
I think it's going to make a change, I almost
think just by thinking about this, recognizing
it.
I think it's going to change anyway, because,
fortunately, we live in a capitalist country.
The fact is, not only is it-- It is in fact
more efficient, it saves money, when the doctor
has enough time to do a good job, get the
right diagnosis, take you off the medications
you don't need.
It saves money.
I think once the capitalist health systems
realizes that it's cheaper to give doctors
enough time to see patients, than it is to
whittle us down so that we just have to order
a whole bunch of tests, it will change on
its own, I do believe.
I just think there's kind of a will out there,
because the doctors, they'll love what I'm
saying here, and the patients, everybody.
It's like a trip.
>>male #2: I'm curious, did Terry have substance
issues, and was becoming sober [clears throat]
part of her recovery?
>>Sweet: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
But as you probably know, making that decision
to become sober.
It really was--
When she went in that room, I can remember
right now, we were all just cringing.
This had happened over and over again.
We were just sure Mike and she would be rolling
out together.
And when I saw-- It still gives me shivers.
When I saw Mike walk out of that-- The door
opened, he walks out, and he's by himself.
And I remember him walking out the ward, we
had swinging doors, and he went through the
doors and they swing shut.
Then Terry rolled herself out of that room
back to her bed.
I was like, "Wow.
Something happened there."
And then, of course, she did give up smoking.
Once she gave up smoking, everything sort
of fell into place.
But why, I don't know.
I don't really know.
Yes.
>>male #3: With the popularity of your book,
have the decision makers at any of the medical
facilities reached out to you to learn how
they can reproduce the success of your experience?
>>Sweet: I'm starting to get a few things
like that.
[pause] But it's really just starting.
I'm getting invitations to talk at different
places.
I've had a few, but I'm actually wanting to
get like Washington-level, because they have--
huh?
>>male #3: inaudible
>>Sweet: [scoffs] I don't know, what about
the surgeon emperor or something.
[laughter] Really powerful, you know?
Yes.
>>female #2: When I look at the medical profession
here, and actually, I should just add a footnote:
my mother is actually currently in hospital.
She's been in for a couple weeks, and probably
be in another week.
But I feel very comfortable about that--
>>Sweet: Is she here, or in Italy?
>>female #2: because she's not in America,
she's in Italy.
So I think she's going to be fine.
[laughter] Well, I mean that seriously, because,
anyway.
I mean, a lot of that's the talk you're giving
here.
But one of the issues in America that I see
that's very different is everybody seems to
want a quick pill fix-it thing, and if they
don't get a quick fix-it, they go to the legal
system.
So one of the issues that I keep thinking
comes up around medicine, why it is the way
it is in this country, is a lot around malpractice,
financial covering your ass, a bunch of stuff
like that.
If you switch into being more inefficient
and human, the doctors are going to have to
spend more time with their patients--
>>Sweet: Absolutely.
>>female #2: which means fewer patients.
The whole equation in this country is in one
direction, and all of this-- Of course there's
that other piece, that all too many doctors
seem to be focused on the money, and not so
much on the caring.
That's the stereotype that I see around.
All these pieces play in to an equation, as
you were describing, that's around money and
efficiency and this and that and forms.
About covering your ass and covering your
pocketbook.
I'd like to know more about, you know.
>>Sweet: Well, there are alternatives.
To me, what we need in this country is an
experiment.
In a way, Laguna Honda for me was an experiment.
I have many, many cases where it's quite clear
that the Laguna Honda treatment-- Terry is
a perfect example.
You can say, "Two and a half years in the
hospital, that's huge."
But before she'd been in the hospital, she'd
been going back and forth, getting $100,000
operations.
Back and forth.
You could say, "Why treat her at all?" and
that's a different discussion.
But if we're going to take care of people,
then I was quite sure, from what I saw at
Laguna Honda, that it was cheaper the Laguna
Honda way: to take the time.
I can give you a very practical example.
Doctors are cheap.
One of the things that's happened in this
country is the economists, when they were
trying to cut costs, they assumed doctors
were really expensive, so they've been de-skilling
doctoring onto nursing and nursing onto dadadadada.
But in fact, doctors are quite cheap.
I'll make $100 an hour.
If I spend an hour with the patient, and that
hour allows me not to get an $1800 MRI, we're
way ahead of the game.
So I think one place to start is to just have
a model and show that, because if they show
that Kaiser and HMOs, then everybody's going
to go, "Well, that's way cheap.
We'll just give doctors back their time.
That is cheaper."
In terms of malpractice, of course there's
all that, and it's complicated, but I will
say this: that the malpractice, what they
say is that you do not actually get sued as
a physician when you make a mistake.
You get sued when the patient feels you didn't
care about them.
I have found that to be the case so far.
I really have.
I think a lot of the malpractice issue is
a little bit of a covering.
I think we could do this.
I think what's going to happen, it actually
is happening.
While I was writing this book-- This is actually
happening, because what's happening is doctors
are saying they can't take it any more and
they're doing this concierge whatever, boutique
whatever kind of stupid name they've got for
it.
This idea that it's more like CSA, like Community
Sponsored Agriculture, where you pay upfront,
you pay $100 a month or $150 a month and the
doctor gets his patients upfront.
Instead of having to have 1000 patients to
pay his bills, he doesn't need any back office
because he gets paid upfront.
He can have 250 patients, and with those 250
patients, he has all the time in the world
to take care of them.
So that's actually an experiment that's a
hidden experiment that's going on right now.
It's very interesting.
The patients are thrilled, the doctors are
thrilled.
It's very interesting
Yes.
>>male #4: I really admit that I may not know
the facts correctly in this, but I understand
that there's something of a shortage of doctors.
If doctors are inexpensive, then we should
have more of them.
Is there something we should be doing to foster
more doctors being out there so we can have
more slow medicine?
>>Sweet: Well, that's a complicated question.
You don't know, and I don't really know, but
I think there's two pieces of it.
The shortage is in what they like to call
primary care doctors.
I'm an internist.
I'm like the front person to take care of
you.
And there seems to be a shortage.
Why?
I don't want to do it.
I don't want to get an unbelievably complicated
patient and have ten minutes to spend with
the patient, of which I spend three minutes
on the computer, seven minutes-- You can't
do it.
So what you're having is doctors are not going
into primary care.
They're going into subspecialties.
And if I had a kid who's going into medicine,
I would tell them, "Do not do what I did.
You get yourself a nice little specialty where
you can do a good job, and you can have a
satisfying practice."
So I think there's plenty of doctors, but
they're not going into primary care.
That's one thing.
The second thing is my generation of doctors
are dropping out of the system like flies.
We don't want to.
We love taking care of patients.
I think if we could take care of patients
the way we wanted, I think it's a little bit--
That's my sense, is there's probably plenty
of doctors, but shifting who does what is
more the issue than educating more docs.
[applause]